the Joe Rogan experience my kids found
out about Harry Hill's and from Monsters
Inc uh-huh and they were like who's that
Harry houses yeah and I said well he's
the guy that made all the early monster
movies and so then we sat down and we
watched King Kong together then they
were scared at first like oh my god I'm
scared but they started laughing when
they saw King Kong this time oh [ __ ]
yeah I mean it's it's today in
comparison to you know even comparison
to your version of King Kong when you
could you know make it mechanized and
you know it's just it's it's amazing
when you think about how far we came but
you know the yes the stop motion and and
Harry hasn't didn't animate on King Kong
he did mighty Joe Young uh but King Kong
is what inspired him
that was Willis O'Brien and Pete
Peterson who were the animators
undoubtly he did the was the the one the
one with Medusa did he do that one huh
Harry Hudson yeah yeah Clash of the
Titans right that was him right well I
can and Ray was a one-man show you know
and stop-motion you know it's 24 frames
a second himself all himself and when
you're animating seven Scott and Jason
the Argonauts there's seven skeletons
fighting seven rise he did all that I'm
Sam himself and I became I became
friends with Ray Wow
and I would say to him and this was
during the time when computer stuff was
starting out you know and you know his
movies were 50,000 dollar movies you
know you know the whole bunch of the
movie you know not just as effects in
the early ones that he did you know and
I said you know it doesn't it piss you
off that now they get millions of
dollars and there's hundreds of people
working on stuff that you did by
yourself you know and well they didn't
ever take away his legacy though you
know even though he did it all but him
he was not just a groundbreaker
but the he's the guy when you think
about stop Maish stop-motion films and
horror films he's the guy that you think
and you pull up jason and the argonauts
skeleton scene I can't believe he did
that all himself I mean that's a very
very detailed notion that scene no cuz
you have to match what they're doing
yeah I mean and you know you're in a
room by yourself and you know moving up
you know fraction of an inch a puppet at
a time you know and it takes not ever
you knowing I mean
I mean if you've never done stop-motion
appreciated oh my god what year was this
I'm not sure exactly
and look they pop out of the ground yeah
oh it's a great bernard herrmann music
in this you know he always had the
terrific scores and his in his films as
well you know and again he was a fan he
who made a living doing something that
he loved you know him and imagine being
the actors and having to sort of respond
to all this yeah
to these skeletons they're popping out
of the ground with shields and swords
which aren't there would you know which
you know it came you know months later
yeah
okay you seen the skeleton now yeah
you're scared he's going to take your
soul well ray would kind of direct those
scenes because in most directors don't
know what to do with that kind of story
you know yeah but he was and you know
what I thought was great about Ray is
like so many artists you know aren't
appreciate till after they're gone
you know ray saw the impact he had I
mean I went to his 90th birthday
celebration and him in England where the
the British Film Academy did this great
tribute to Ray and everybody showed up I
mean Peter Jackson came you know people
who didn't show up sent video Steven
Spielberg's in a video Joe Jim Cameron
did all talking about how much raised
films and raised work influenced them
and it was really great you know and is
so nice that he was able to be
appreciated like that in his lifetime
and and now I'm actually I mean the
funny thing is I'm getting that now with
this with my book that's come out people
are just going oh my god you're I love
you so much and the stuff have you done
it's just you know it's nice to know
that you you know I served a purpose you
served a giant purpose and you served a
big purpose in my life man like I said
I'm such a huge fan of your work
[Applause]